[Music]
[Applause]
yesterday was all about CJ Stroud and
his pro day and feels like there's a
foregone conclusion that that's the
number one quarterback in the draft
Lewis joining us now what did you think
going in and what did you think going
out of CJ Stroud's pro day
that's a great question look going in I
Dan I always liked CJ because of his
his calmness in the pocket his ability
to win in the pockets
his size his accuracy his decision
making how the people at Ohio State had
told me that this was a guy who was a
high level processor he was not someone
who's just benefiting from being around
great players and a good scheme and and
you know he didn't have to have you know
really do a whole lot on his own within
that scheme in order to make it work
so I believed all of that when I was
told that and then watching him play on
tape and then seeing him yesterday I'm
going look and talking to the young man
he's got that presence that charisma
that awareness that you want to see in
someone who's being considered to be the
number one overall pick okay you just do
he waited it was yesterday he was six
three two thirteen
he's a slenderly built guy you don't you
don't you wouldn't even think he's 213
pounds you would think yeah he could
easily probably put on 10 15 pounds as
his body matures and all so he's going
to get bigger and stronger
he's just really to me
he's a total package now
what's interesting about this debate
that's going on now between him and
Bryce
is every single I'm standing down here
in Alabama's facility right now as this
you know things get ramped up down here
every single person will tell you and
you've seen him
if you made Bryce 6-2 if he was six two
two thirteen six three two thirteen many
people believe there wouldn't even be a
discussion okay about who the number one
quarterback is and that's really where
the rub is that's where the debate is
that's where the discussion really
Centers do you want the bigger guy
who quite honestly can do a lot of the
things that the smaller guy can do not
everything that he can do but a lot but
many of the things it should be a great
Pro or do you want the smaller guy
who is just absolutely freaking electric
but you may worry about his availability
over a 10-15 year career all right so
I'll make you the GM you're Carolina
you're on the clock
could you make a choice right now even
though you haven't seen Bryce young do
his pro day
you know I'll tell you what I I
get another great question I look
forward to standing next to Brett I want
to see him I want to feel his presence I
want to feel what he feels like standing
next to him
having been a player like I have a good
sense of guys who like to me really like
if it worries me or if it doesn't like
standing next to CJ Stroud I mean this
guy's a typical quarterback he's got a
typical NFL quarterback built
I want to feel what Bryce feels like
standing next to him if that makes sense
and just kind of sense what his what his
body structure looks like and how big
you I just want to see that kind of
thing after that
look I already believed that I would
take CJ Stroud after everything that
I've learned and everything that I've
watched and what I believe you know
leads to longevity at that position some
uh from the body structure standpoint
but
it's hard it's hard to it's hard to go
against the young man
what questions are you allowed to ask on
these Pro days when you're around these
players
you know you really kind of keep it
um
surface level when you're when you're
talking about from a media perspective
right so from a Personnel perspective a
lot of the questions have already been
asked of these guys the scouts the
Personnel directors the GM's
you know they've been into the schools
they have seen him at the combine
they have talked to
all kinds of people who are close to
them to where they are able to gather
the kind of information that they really
need now there's still more in fact
finding that they're gonna that they're
gonna
you know go on as far as trying to make
sure that they've crossed every T dot at
every eye
but by and large
a lot of the information has already
been gathered
the longer this process goes quite
honestly then is when people start to
make mistakes because you start
overthinking the data yes right yes and
you know what else happens at this time
of year
a lot of people start getting into the
decision-making process that quite
honestly weren't in it from the very
beginning and then they started throwing
curveballs at it next thing you know the
people who have been in it from the
beginning who thought they had a good
idea if you're like oh damn I don't even
know what I know anymore well that's why
now I'm second guessing myself but Lewis
I don't know how I would feel if I'm the
coach or GM of the Panthers and David
Tepper is there so the owner is there I
don't want my owner involved in this my
owner became a billionaire not making
football decisions in business this is
where you have to let the people you
hired but David Tepper is going to be
involved in this decision
how would you handle that if you were
the GM
how would you handle that of
uh yeah David we yeah he's he's a really
good player
um yeah yeah I I think he what's funny
is I ate breakfast next to David Temple
this morning you're staying in the same
Hotel so uh he um
I think you'd handle it like this look I
think guys who have made uh fortunes for
themselves like he has
obviously have
very very brilliant sharp minds they
have a great sense about
about business about setting goals about
people and surrounding themselves with
people who are smart and people who have
leadership qualities and who are
intrinsically motivated and also I would
want to lean on
that kind of expertise from an owner in
that regard when it came when it comes
to
you know a quarterback's movement in the
pocket whether or not you know
operating out of the gun or the pistol
or under Center I would be like hey why
don't you leave that stuff to us okay
we'll we'll handle that yeah but but as
far as the personality evaluation yeah I
think there's there's without a doubt
there's something that owners can
definitely provide in that regarding and
quite honestly at the end you know at
the end of the day
it's his team so I I don't I don't mind
it yeah but it's your job your your
job's at stake too off this pick he
doesn't get fired that's true and I
think that's where like I'm big on
relationships and big on communication
and I think that's something that in the
beginning when you're maybe interviewing
for one of these jobs in your
prospective GM and you're going to take
the job you say Hey look when we have
these kind of decisions whenever we come
up I hope you will give me your word
that you'll lean on my expertise for the
things that you're hiring me for and not
have me sitting here second guessing
myself and or changing my opinions
because I'm trying to appease you
because then things get all screwed up
then I'm not really doing my job so
don't even hire me if you're going to do
that to me I think those are the kind of
things that you need to be honest about
talking to Louis Riddick he's at Bryce
Young's Pro Day the former player ESPN
NFL analyst what could Bryce young do
today
that would secure being the number one
overall pick in the draft
yeah I don't really think it makes a
difference then I mean you people well
he's gonna he's gonna tear it up out
here I mean he's in shorts he's going to
be throwing the guys who's he's already
thrown to he knows what throws he's
going to do
he knows what it's going to feel like
he's he's a big game hunter anyway he's
been in these kind of situations before
me thrown in front of Scouts he's
throwing in front of 90 100 000 people
it's not gonna matter to him
so I don't think there's anything he can
really do what this is really this is
just another box checking uh
you know scenario for Scouts and GMS to
kind of say well we've covered all of
our bases because I mean the further you
get away from playing the games again
that's where you start making mistakes
in terms of your evaluation go back to
the tape go back to the character
assessment go back to the football and
personal character assessment go back to
the medical
use all that stuff then to arrive at
your at a decision that best fits your
football team relative to what you can
offer the young man this this pro day
really is just confirmation it's really
just again checking off a box making
yourself feel better
about probably a decision that you're
probably well down the road to already
making anyway
I don't know if this player was on Aaron
Rodgers list but what did you think of
the Jets picking up Nicole Hardman and
trading away Elijah Moore
I'm kind of disappointed to be honest
with you yeah I mean I loved how
electric he is saw him in training camp
last year
um before we did their money in that
game in the preseason what do we not
know about this situation because if I'm
Aaron Rodgers I want him Nicole Hardman
can run fast yeah Elijah Moore can make
plays yeah he sure can I think there's
there's a couple there's probably a
couple layers to it I mean that it
sounds like from the you know from the
details of the trade that they were able
to pick up a a higher draft pick as well
I think they were able to acquire a two
uh by trading him away
and Nicole you're right McColl and him
are not really the same player they
don't have the same skill set for sure I
agree with you a thousand percent yeah I
think this is all part of a bigger
picture but well part of a bigger plan
so to make sure that they have the right
assets to try and acquire Aaron because
it's uh
that that that's the more interesting
thing to me Dan is like exactly what
does this what is a trade parameters for
Aaron Rodgers actually look like like
what is
there's just some people who believe
like the Jets didn't do anything because
the Packers have to trade them because
if they don't it just cripples in salary
cap wise so why should the Jets be
sweating trying to offer them all kinds
of stuff to make them happy while at the
same time people for some people say
well
Green Bay doesn't have to do anything
either because the Jets don't have a
plan B without Aaron Rodgers so it's
it's an interesting stare down between
these two you know to figure out which
one's going to really wind up winning
this deal
because both teams have an argument to
say hey look we don't have to do
anything but we don't have to do
anything either
it's kind of interesting
and at the same you know while we sit
there on their ways and talk about it
day after day oh I know I know I feel
for you guys because I talk about it you
know only when I want to talk about it
not when I'm told to talk about it I
hear you yes hey talk about the Cowboys
today what are we talking about
um I I don't know
make something up keep fighting a good
fight there and do it in a real subtle
way when you walk up to stand next to
Bryce young that he doesn't realize that
you're measuring yourself yes yeah yes I
will I won't I won't give them the up
and down like yeah yeah I'll try not to
although I know I'll be doing it though
hey have fun uh great to talk to you
thanks for joining us of course man
thanks that's Louis Riddick the
mothership he's at Bryce Young's pro day
that starts in about 15 minutes